[Música]
vamos ahora con nuestros invitados desde
el día invitados de lujo en el marco de
los cinco años de Francia 24 en español
el 26 de septiembre del año 2017 pues es
ya lanzamos nuestra cadena completamente
en español comenzamos con seis horas al
aire Luego pasamos a 12 horas y ya
estamos con 24 horas de programación
noticias internacionales completamente
en español y nos acompaña Entonces en
este momento Vanessa ya es la directora
general de Francia 24 las cuatro cadenas
en inglés francés español y árabe
Vanessa bienvenida
muy buenos días y también por supuesto
estamos con nuestro director general de
Francia 24 en español Álvaro Sierra
Álvaro como siempre como no tenerle
momentos tan especiales Raúl todo un
honor que nos tengas en directo América
muchas gracias a ustedes por pues
atender la invitación a nuestro programa
el día de hoy vamos a comenzar con
Vanessa cinco años en nuestra cadena en
español Cómo ha sido nuestro crecimiento
buen aniversario a todo el equipo de
Francia 24 en Bogotá y en todos los
corresponsales que participan que
trabajan para la cadena en español del
aniversario para todos estén muy
orgullosos de su trabajo por todos esos
cinco años de trabajo porque la cadena
en español en este momento está
implantada en el Continente
latinoamericano con muy buenos números
tres medios de espectadores semanales
que se me dio en Colombia México y
Argentina y hay esta cifra en YouTube
también un millón de suscriptores que
tienen en este momento en YouTube Así
que estén orgullosos de su trabajo la
cadena que en este momento están bien
implantada en el Continente
latinoamericano Gracias Vanessa y pues
por supuesto siempre un placer seguir
creciendo aquí en Francia 24 en español
y todas las Pues de Francia 24 Álvaro
También tenemos en estos cinco años
nuevos programas Y también vamos a
lanzar programas en las plataformas
digitales que cada día pues se cobran
más importancia en la vida de todos los
seres humanos todos los ciudadanos pues
digitalizados no sí sí Exacto Sí vamos a
hacer varias cosas nuevas ya tenemos
decidida una parte y a lo largo del año
próximo de 2023 creo que vamos a seguir
introduciendo novedades tanto en la
parrilla de televisión como en un área
que es clave para el futuro que es toda
la parte digital web redes sociales por
ahora vamos a completar nuestra franja
regional tenemos programas que son aquí
América África siete días Europa hoy
Francia en foco vamos a tener un
programa enfocado en Asia que se llamará
así es Asia que va a presentar Paula
Jiménez y otro programa que se va a
llamar Expreso de oriente enfocado en el
medio oriente que lo va a presentar
Marina sardina dos de nuestras
periodistas y En tercer lugar vamos a
completar la franja nocturna de lunes a
viernes del debate con un de pero un
debate especial los viernes que se llama
una semana en el mundo las tres cuatro
grandes noticias de de de esa semana
digamos se van a poner en ese horario
que completa de lunes a viernes el
debate y vamos a lanzar empezamos ya
haciendo un podcast de El Debate y vamos
a lanzar cinco o seis nuevos podcasts
algunos con Crónica muy populares como
la que acabamos de ver con un mar La
Crónica de Salud La Crónica de historia
la revista de prensa y la revista
digital entre otros hay varios otros
podcast en el en la cocina pero hasta
íbamos con eso arrancamos Esta esta este
Después de cinco años esta nueva etapa
estos cinco años o felices y por
supuesto Francia 24 repotenciado con
estos programas que no se pueden perder
Vanessa vuelvo contigo para hablar un
poco digamos de la diferencia que aporta
France 24 en español en América Latina
digamos en un panorama internacional de
cadenas de información bastante
concurrido que pues nos diferencia a
nosotros
tiene una particularidad eso es una
cadena de servicio público que licua
valores franceses Y esa es la diferencia
con otras cadenas en el Continente
Cuáles son los valores franceses
los Derechos Humanos la defensa de la
Democracia la defensa de las minorías la
igualdad entre hombres y mujeres que es
muy muy importante para las 24 y defensa
de la laicidad pero también somos una
cadena de grandes reportajes y insisto
mucho en esto porque esa es la
diferencia hemos hablado con Álvaro
sobre el paisaje mediático en América
Latina y queremos hacer un énfasis en
los reportajes tenemos unos sobre la
guerra en Ucrania en las cuatro lenguas
teníamos 17 periodistas en el terreno y
cuatro periodistas de la cadena en
español
es la cadena de la explicación realmente
explicamos las noticias y eso es lo que
queremos hacer como las 24 y no hay que
olvidarlo también la cultura es esa la
cual continúa a hacer soñar a la gente
ya sea a través de la música la danza la
gastronomía francesa quiero hacerle a
los dos tanto activan esa también como
Álvaro porque hace un año también
estabas aquí con nosotros en Pues el
estreno de nuestro programa matinal
directo América Vanessa Cómo ha sido
digamos a nuestro crecimiento y la
importancia de una matinal de dos horas
en medio de información llamada directo
a América
todo su equipo
yo no veo con todo con él la diferencia
horaria lo veo en París es un programa
muy muy bueno que tiene un muy buen
ritmo Tenemos muchos temas la economía
el deporte de la salud
todos esos temas que nos interesan de
forma diaria con dos invitados lo cual
el cual es un momento hablamos de
actualidad hablamos de la frontera entre
Colombia y Venezuela ustedes tenían su
corresponsal
en el lugar Así que es bastante
ecléctico esta Este programa y es una
fortaleza y felicitaciones porque lo
representa muy muy bien hacer programas
mucha energía
Álvaro pues vamos a hablar también sobre
esto no ya un año directo América de
Francia 24 Me acuerdo cuando pues me
acerqué a tu oficina decirte que pues
teníamos esta idea y bueno nada desde el
punto la coma desde la primera palabra
pues formamos este programa durante
mucho tiempo y ya hace un año lo
estrenamos Álvaro pues tus impresiones
de directo América directo América es en
cierta medida igual a los cinco años de
francés 24 de todo el canal Eh Esto fue
producto de una creación colectiva
acuerdos lo recuerdo muy bien la idea
original La propuso Raúl la discutimos
en reuniones que armamos de toda la
redacción como hemos discutido otros
programas y aquí estamos un año después
yo quiero aprovechar para mencionar el
directo América nocturno que es como el
hermanito de de la matinal este lo
habíamos empezado pero es coinciden el
lanzamiento del directo América nocturno
de 7 a 9 de la noche ahora Bogotá quito
Lima con con el aniversario y los cinco
años entonces ya tenemos dos estas dos
franjas de directo muy importantes muy
muy al estilo de France 24 porque son
franjas muy informativas No son no son
franjas de entretenimiento como
funcionan en América Latina sino que son
franjas de información de de cristal de
de análisis de la noticia como como lo
mencionaba Vanessa Entonces el futuro
con Vanessa lo hemos hablado mucho el
futuro en televisión es el directo y
mientras más directos podamos tener
creemos que más más consolidamos la
audiencia El próximo paso va a ser la
tercera hermanita que es directo América
de 12 a 2 de la tarde Así es Álvaro y
pues por supuesto con los brazos
abiertos o para este estreno de lo que
va a ser pues muy pronto Ojalá así sea
este directo América de 12 a 12 de la
tarde hora de Bogotá quito de Lima de
verdad Vanessa un placer como siempre
tenerte aquí con nosotros en nuestra
reacción de Bogotá Muchísimas gracias
Pues por todo tu apoyo siempre para
nuestro crecimiento
y también Álvaro también te quería dar
las gracias por siempre apoyarnos y pues
estar liderando todo este proyecto de
Francia 24 en español y de esta manera
entonces ponemos punto final en lo que
fue nuestros dos invitados de el día
nosotros continuamos esto es directo
América